[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
and the series called tin talk my name
is Dena ibraimi and I will be your host
today so without further Ado let's dive
it into today's episode and embark on a
great journey together get ready to be
engaged entertained and inspired today
topic will be about the impact of fast
food on adolescence to help us explore
this topic we have on expert in
Adolescence Health and ination with us
today Dr Alisa a welcome
Dr thank you for having me Denisa it's a
pleasure to be here to discuss this
important issue absolutely so let's
start with the basics why is fast food
such a popular choice among teenagers
fast food is everywhere and it's
designed for convenience teenagers often
lead busy lives with school
extracurricular activities and social
commitments fast food establishments
offer quick tasty and affordable options
making it a tempting Choice when time is
limited that makes sense but what are
some of the health implications of
relying on fast food as a primary source
of
nutrition fast food tends to be high in
calories
saturated fats sodiums and sugars while
lacking essential nutrients like fiber
vitamins and minerals overc consumption
can lead to weight gain increased risk
of obesity and a higher likelihood of
developing chronic health conditions
like type 2 diabetes heart disease and
hypertension it's also linked to poor
dental health and can affect mental
well-being right and many teenagers are
at the stage that their where their
bodies are still developing who can fix
that mention they're longterm uh healthy
adolescence is a critical period for
growth and development poor eating
habits during these years can have long
lasting effects on a teenager's Health
they might not immediately notice the
consequences but these choices can set
the stage for chronic health issues in
adulthood it's certainly a cause for
concern but Beyond in individual health
how does this prevent prevailance of
fast food impact our
communities fast food can contribute to
a host of community issues too it's
often found found in lowincome
neighborhoods leading to a lack of
access to healthier food options this
can perpetuate Health disparities and
contribute to CommunityWide health
issues additionally fast food can
contribute to environmental problems
through excess packaging and waste those
are some important points to consider so
what can teenagers uh and uh their
family do to make healthier choice and
red uh reduce their impact of fast food
education is key teenagers and their
families can learn more about nutrition
and the importance of balanced diets
they can also make small changes in
their eating habits like cooking at home
more often choosing healthier menu
options when they do eat out and being
mindful of portion sizes it's also
crucial to advocate for better access to
healthy foods and communities excellent
advice finally as we wrap up our
discussion what's your top takeway for
teenagers and their families when it
comes to fast food my top takeaway is
this moderation is key it's okay to
enjoy fast foods occasionally but it
shouldn't be a regular part of your diet
make a conscious effort to eat a variety
of foods including fruits vegetables and
whole grains and remember that good
nutrition is an investment in your
long-term health and well-being thank
you so much Dr a for sharing your
expertise of this important topic you're
very welcome it's been a pleasure to be
here thank you so much for joining us on
this episode of uh te talk it's been an
incredible journey and we're so glad you
came alone for the ride until next time
take care thank you again
[Music]
goodbye
oh